[Music]
hi everybody I'm Andy Chang product
manager and Google's cloud security team
I'm joined here by dan I'm a Danny male
and with Capital One and I perform in
our cloud governance and compliance
space for our multi cloud environments
and dan and I will be splitting the
presentation duties I'll do the
beginning part Dan will talk about
Capital One's experience living this in
the cloud and then we'll wrap up sure
when I start I'm gonna maybe ask you a
question I had got last that question
now what's in your wallet so I'll start
with actually a cautionary tale so stay
tuned for that and you're gonna see a
slide that you're probably not used to
at Google presentations of this type
thank you for having cool so you're in
SEC 209 shared responsibility what this
means for you as a C so and I think
hopefully you're benefiting for some of
the comfiest chairs for any of the talks
much better than the ones in the large
stage area so you know as you've
probably since you've been into a few of
these sessions we're also taking
questions in the Dory and so go to your
app if you have questions that come up
as we're talking
please enter those in and we'll handle
them towards the end we'll be covering a
few things you know the overall one of
the questions that I get talking to
customers is what is the exact split on
the shared responsibility model how do I
understand it how do i leverage that how
do I make sure that the cloud provider
is doing what they supposed to do and
that my own company's doing what we're
supposed to do so I talked a little bit
about perceptions of what customers care
about in security the understanding that
shared responsibility division focusing
on visibility and control and then
ultimately focusing on a quick
architecture example then I'll turn it
over to Dan to kind of talk you through
the lived experience at Capital One how
they've been successful on multiple
public clouds and then we'll wrap up
with questions and answers
so when customers talk to me things I
hear that folks care about are really
that the right data is delivered to the
right customer at the right point in
time for the right purpose
each and every time and that's some of
the core of security the right thing and
only the right thing happens when it's
supposed to happen
in addition given as we all see the
current threat environment and the
activity of threat actors increasing
it's important not just to react wet
situations but also to to be able to
anticipate and innovate ahead of through
these threats addition many of you are
in regular to regulated environments so
it's important partner to be able to
essentially enable you to deliver on
your responsibilities while running your
businesses in the public cloud and
lastly and really the focus of this is
understanding and having a clear
understanding of possibility model I
think we're gonna switch over to
it's here okay so now we're I think this
is - sorry folks give us one second to
get this straight now
okay all right so this is better
cool all right so we're gonna technical
difficulties
cool alright can you guys hear me okay
we're gonna go with that hand mic and
see if how this goes thank you so we're
gonna you know the focus of this talk is
really on the understanding enabling you
guys to understand where that split is
from a shared responsibility standpoint
and really ultimately for you as CISOs
as you as folks part of the security
part of the organization enabling you to
actually accelerate your company's
business velocity with enabling your
stakeholders to have and understand
really what is the controllable and
acceptable amount of risk so really
focusing on this area at Google the way
we think about the shared responsibility
model is really around two key items
security of the cloud and security in
the cloud and we'll talk about how we
divvy those things up in a moment from a
core principle standpoint security at
Google is done defense-in-depth we have
at least two layers of protections that
are independent from each other between
anything of interest anything you want
to protect and any kind of bad activity
or threat actor at scale so as you can
imagine Google I think other folks have
said we're twenty five percent plus of
the internet our traffic standpoint
things done at Google for security or
for other things have to be done fully
at scale and work at scale and by
default right how do we enable our
developers how do we enable the system
so that the controls that are necessary
required are enabled by default and so
that folks can run at the core
underlying this is really the use of
strong cryptographic credentials and
identity and what that means is that
whether it's a machine whether it's a
human whether it's the data whether it's
the code whether it's the underlying
service they all have unique
cryptographic identities that we can
compare against what should be happening
and provenance the ability to establish
through a hardware root of trust that
the underlying hardware the low-level
software the OS software the
applications that are running are all
fully attested to at each stage and that
we're writing running and write the
right code at the right time the other
part of this is that you know at Google
we think Trust isn't gained just through
technology but also through transparency
and really what that means to you and to
customers in general is thinking about
reducing what we call the unverifiable
trust surface what that means is
minimizing the amount you actually have
to trust us as a cloud provider having
you being provided enough information so
you can make a decision on of your own
to verify the claims that we're making
and that's a core part of what we're
trying to do ultimately we're interested
in providing customers the capabilities
to help you build secure applications
and fulfill your part of the shared
responsibility model when we think about
the controls that are in place we really
think about them in three kind of areas
underlying control things that really
help you protect the data visibility the
ability to classify the data and monitor
the actions on that data and then
detection response the ability actually
validate the controls running and detect
essentially things that are
non-compliant activities that could be
threats or from bad actors and for each
of these areas we have technology that
we provide to enable that when we think
about the shared responsibility model
it's important to understand that the
boundaries of that share responsibility
vary based on which types of services
you're using and for many of our
customers they're using a spectrum of
services which is why it's not
surprising that as you because a CSO or
as a part of the security team the
details of for what service in which
part can add to additional complexity
and so it's important to understand
where those divisions are when you're
running on premise where everything in
the blue represents the customer so when
you're running on premise you own all of
your hardware stack your relationships
the underlying software running so not
surprisingly the full responsibility is
really on you as the customer when
you're running as an infrastructure of
service which is essentially running
your own virtual machines on our
platform but installing your own images
setting up your own network
architectures the responsibility for us
is to provide you the ability to log in
audit the things that are running on the
system the network the underlying
hardware and infrastructure the pieces
that you're building on top of so that
the services we provide to you are
secure and then you're responsible for
putting those things together in secure
architectures when are you writing a
platform
as a service like bigquery or App Engine
one of those things now really you're
providing us code that you're running
and we're responsible for delivering the
underlying services that execute that
code in a safe and secure way and when
you're using software that we've
provided now we're responsible as well
for the code so if you're using Gmail or
drive or Docs that code is then become
part of Arc's responsibility and then
the thing that you focus on is access to
those applications access to the data
that you provide and then the data that
you're loading into those applications
that's kind of a quick summary of the
different levels and we'll go into some
of this in more detail so as we talked
about from a Google perspective we think
about security of the cloud and in the
cloud of the cloud is the core about the
core infrastructure that you're then
using and the core services to build
your products and applications for your
consumers for Google we're responsible
for security of the cloud and we think
about it as again defense-in-depth at
scale by default we model kind of the
underlying architecture that you're
running on top of in nine layers
everything from the hardware all the way
through the underlying low-level
software the applications and ultimately
to usage and everything that we do at
Google is rooted in a hardware root of
trust which is the titan chip that
you've heard of through last couple kind
of next conferences it's a purpose-built
chip that we've built and it sits on our
compute cards or processor cards and
establishes on boot a cryptographic
identity for that piece of hardware and
verifies that all the underlying pieces
of software that are meant to boot are
doing so in the right way that the
hardware components are correct and in
configured the right way and if any of
those things fail that card or that
compute instance does not actually boot
and be entered into the fleet and that
allows us to make sure once something
goes through that it's in a known good
State and it can be put into the rest of
the fleet and start serving customers
and those that becomes the underlying
piece that drives our servers our
storage our network and then ultimately
our data centers and what that allows us
to do then is reduce the threat for
folks injecting either malicious
hardware malicious software into our
systems in combination with that as we
talked about at the beginning it's
important for us at Google that we have
the ability for the code that we write
for the to define that the right
identity access is the right machine is
authorized by the right code accessing
the right data and it's in the right
time and context and that's done through
a cryptographically secure identities so
not only users have identities machines
and services have identities devices
have identities and then code and data
have identities and checking all of
those things when we run a Google
service is a core part of our underlying
platform here's a stack a little more
detail of the different pieces within
Google that come into play to secure
each layer you'll see that there's at
least two items at each layer that are
put together to provide redundancy and
really defense in depth whether it's the
purpose-built underlying infrastructure
or the fact that we from a boot
standpoint cryptographically sign all
the pieces of our boot software from an
operating system and hypervisor
standpoint we use our own version of KVM
where we stripped out very lot of parts
of the virtual machine monitor reduce
its attack surface and risk surface
we've also then added sandboxing in so
that further creates a level of
isolation from an OS standpoint we use
our own curated operating system for our
host side we also make that available as
the container optimize OS for you as a
customer to use if you're using our
container optimized OS you can also
enable automatic updates which will
patch the container optimize OS so you
can leverage and benefit from the same
type of security controls we have when
we run on our host side from a storage
and network standpoint unique to cloud
providers all services all data is
encrypted at rest and in transit at
Google the logging of kind of both
internal Googler access as well as
providing audit logs for your users and
your systems
what they do in your systems an identity
access management system that allows us
to do fine-grained permissions and then
really managing those keys that are core
part of encryption at scale from a
networking side we have one of the
world's largest private networks what
that means is that from when your data
or your service is touched by a customer
from outside our network it basically
travels wholly on Google owned private
networking private fiber to the server
in our systems and that gives you not
only performance advantages but gives
you a single threat to choke from a
network security standpoint there are no
additional actors in the end the
underlying hops from an application
standpoint both from the whole software
lifecycle from static analysis to the
patching and checking of the packages
that are loaded in we have control over
that
we also cryptographically sign each
piece of software as it goes through a
development stage and then check before
it's deployed that the manifest has all
the right policies applied that's
something external eyes to customers as
a part of binary authorization so if you
want to adopt that same model that you
can run vulnerability checks various
types of patching checks static code
analysis and then as long as code passes
that create a cryptographic signature
and have that check before the code is
deployed able to do that through our
binary authorization product this once
the applications are up and running
they're protected by our own global
front-end and the web capabilities and
DDoS capabilities around that and then
we provide as well our own security
scanning for l7 web application
vulnerabilities that we use inside of
Google as a product called cloud
security scanner for you to use as a
customer when things are deployed at
scale we were very fond of saying that
your first users are typically abusers
so whenever we deploy a service we see a
lot of attack traffic therefore the
built-in DDoS for our own services the
ability to be our own CA so it's very
hard for folks to forge anything related
to kind of connecting to Google and that
all services provider Google are at full
TLS
finally from an operation standpoint not
just trusting us but having third
parties do compliance checking the
ability to do live migration which
enables us to do patching of live
running VMs without taking your services
down allows us to on a continuous basis
do that level of patching and keeping
things up is of highest level security
and then we have full sock threat
analysis and the ability from a user
standpoint to connect to our services
through beyond Corp as your trust type
network as well as the will for them to
do a hardware base second factor for a
security key and that is the structure
for every service created at Google and
used it's Google and the tools in which
you would then build on top of when you
use one of our services we think about
enabling customers we do this providing
the same type of set of services either
in the dark green as products you can
consume in the light green as either
products that you can use from Google or
that you can get from partners or in the
case of the dark blue core things we
still do by default for you when you're
running on Google cloud platform we're
going to talk and highlight some of the
key differentiators on Google cloud
platform that it will help you do your
job better and fulfill your part of the
shared responsibility from a visibility
and control side so one of the core
things which we announced two general
availability this morning is the cloud
security command center that's that
central pane of glass that you can bring
in detections from Google native
products third-party products or ones
you've written yourself for
vulnerabilities and threats all in one
place and see those in context with your
assets and the business context of those
services and the sensitivity of the data
gives you one place to look for
visibility one thing for you to then
query understand your data and then the
ability to trigger prevention detection
in action in addition what we feel is is
part key partly to understanding the
attack surface is understanding where
your data is and what sensitivity level
that is done what we provide is the same
service we used within Google for the
classification our cloud dlp API which
is designed to work at data at exabyte
and petabytes scales which allows you
then to number-14 data sitting in Google
Cloud storage or data sitting in
BigTable bigquery tables to classify at
scale sensitive data either through our
built-in classifiers the ability use
regular regular expressions or to
express this in terms of data sets that
we can train our models on once you've
identified that data you would then have
the choice of multiple D identification
options simple things like substitution
encryption more intricate things like
format preserving encryption or
transformations that allow the data
still to be usable in analytics but
still potent parallel pervert preserve
privacy
in addition unique to Google as we
provide access transparency which means
that we provide you in our audit logs
notice every time a Googler accesses
your data and for what region the reason
what region that Googler was from and
the case number in the case of customer
initiates support events that triggered
that access this is a this is across the
wide range of Google services and unlike
some of the other providers not just
restricted to a small set of the provide
services also at next we're very excited
to announce access approvals which now
allows you to prevent Googlers from
access to the data in real time for a
subset of the data so not only will we
notify you if a Googlers trying to
access data you can actually get the
ability to say you will not allow that
and grant that access and the Googler
will no longer have access to that data
and will note and will not start having
access to that data the results of these
are surfaced in cloud security command
center also through the audit logging
aap is one of the key parts we talked
about earlier was trust through
transparency and so part of that is
there's a lot of things that we've told
you about our technology and how we do
things but you don't have to just trust
us we go through twice a year set of
certifications you'll see some of these
here and that those certifications go on
an ongoing basis working with your sales
teams and with your account teams you
can get
access to some of the reports of these
things so you can see for yourself that
whether its overall global standards or
country specific standards how we do
against the requirements and
certifications you need to run your
businesses we move to control one of the
key things that's unique to Google is an
emphasis on providing out-of-the-box
top-down logically central but globally
distributed controls
we were the first of the cloud providers
to provide organization level viewpoint
a top-down resource hierarchy that also
is an iam boundary and also is a network
boundary so you have the ability to
start your systems and your developers
in a safe mode where they have by design
restricted access that you then can
explicitly only grant through the IAM
roles from an IAM standpoint we have
over 300 curated roles so out-of-the-box
the separation of duties are built in by
those products requiring explicitly
grants for folks to use that we have
hierarchy and inheritance in our
resource hierarchy so if you're given
something at a folder level that person
then can have the underlying roles in
each of the products projects below that
but if you're at a project level you
can't go up the chain unless you're
explicitly granted that type of access
in addition we have org policies that
you can define at the top level that can
be enforced across all your organization
regardless of the underlying pieces and
then we're going to talk about two other
things that affect your communication
pattern VPC service controls which
provide you the ability to find service
perimeters so unlike the traditional l3
l4 networks which are based on routes
and IPs and restrictions of based on IPs
as you move to micro services services
then have unique identities and you have
the ability to block services access to
particular types of sensitive data or
projects and those can be applied to
Google services as well so that you can
block for example Google Storage writes
or reads from particular set of
resources only unless that those
services have either belong to a
particular access level
or have a particular set of permission
groups in addition we also provide a
similar set of capabilities around your
l3 l4 level networking so we have the
ability for you create what's called a
shared VPC and in that shared VPC define
all the firewall rules that apply to all
the tenant v pcs so you have again one
logical choke point where you can
provide the administration of your
overall network and separate and
independent from the underlying
administrators of the other life
projects both of these concepts are
designed to provide you logical
bottlenecks and choke points for control
but not cost you anything on the
performance side because they're
implemented in globally distributed ways
and those are unique to Google V PC
service codes controls as I talked about
is really defining service level
perimeters which allow you to put that
around specific sets of sensitive data
allow you to define access levels and
those access levels allow you to put
policy requirements for example of what
kind of geographies that the data can be
accessed from what kind of restricted
IPs what tichel device characteristics
are needed to access that data those
access context levels apply not only to
infrastructure controls like this but
also back into your G suite access to
Doc's in Gmail so in one construct
access levels you can define a set of
controls that apply across both G suite
and GC P similarly from a key management
standpoint as I talked about by default
your data is encrypted at rest and in
transit but we know for some of our
customers they have additional either
regular retire requirements or views of
their threat model or risk that require
greater control of their keys so we
provide a full spectrum from the left
default encryption you don't have to do
anything your data is encrypted at rest
cloud key management system which allows
you full control of creation of keys
destruction of keys rotation times and
periods full logging iam roles on those
keys so you can demonstrate to your
regularly
and others that you have full control of
keys cloud HSM which can is a hardware
back solution so that you can have the
route of trust for those kms keys be in
hardware and it's a fifth level three
Hardware Clovelly distributed cloud HSM
system you can also if you need to have
the key the root keys be sourced within
your own org you can use cloud
essentially this customer supplied
encryption keys which allows you to push
the encryption keys to us when you need
something decrypted we do not store that
key it stays only in memory for the live
operation and therefore you have not
only the root of trust in your own
hardware system and we have no access to
those online keys you can also have
essentially the ability to stack HSM
your own HSMs in our coalos if you want
that further level additional control on
essentially customer supplied encryption
keys so depending on the risk parameters
of your business you have a full
spectrum of capabilities available to
support data encryption and before I
turn it over to Dan I'm gonna talk
through now how the various controls get
put together when you think about a
secure architecture so first most
customers start with a clean slate they
have an existing on-premise or other
cloud installation they have identity
setup typically not a Google identity
out of the box from an enterprise
standpoint local compute gateways and
then data so the first thing to do is to
essentially connect to cloud I daddy
which lets us federating identity
service and now brings those identities
to be used in cloud in Google cloud
platform then through the groups and the
underlying individuals a sign out the I
am roles in policies did you want so
that folks have the correct separation
of duties the ability established
upfront org level policies that apply
regardless of the underlying pieces
across your whole organization for
example that VMs cannot have publicly
facing internet addresses then the
ability to fine again from l3 l4 level
and overall control of your firewall
rules and networking through shared V
pcs
breaking out from an H a standpoint and
a disaster recovery standpoint the
various regional pieces do you want to
allocate within each of the regions the
zones the resource allocation and then
the underlying subnet connections by
default and unique to Google our
networks are global by default so you're
able to make those connections very
straightforward you don't have to pair
between the different regions our V pcs
are global by nature and you're able to
therefore set up you know H a and D are
very and very straightforward way next
thing you want to do ultimately is you
have data sitting your on-prem and you
want to bring it securely into GCP or
take the data that we compute and bring
it back to your on-prem so common to
combining cloud router firewall rules
dedicated secure interconnect either
through our own peering or through
partner peering allows you to bring the
data in and out of your area securely
also we have VPNs to allow you to do
that as well
next piece then is from an application
standpoint protect your application once
you serve it from the typical attacks
like DDoS so you can either use our
default global load balancer which as
long as you put that in front of one of
your GCE services will take advantage of
our global front-end you can use one of
our managed services which has DDoS
built-in or you can use the cloud armor
product which gives you additional
availability and the ability to write
your own rules to fine-grained manage
your DDoS and woth next piece then is
you want to turn on logging so that you
have the monitoring and evidence of
things that might happen allow us to do
detections and audit logs are turned on
by default you can also look at VPC flow
logs firewall logs and then general
logging then you want to turn on the
monitoring learning and detection pieces
which include the cloud security command
center security health analytics the
ability to look at stackdriver
monitoring running security scanner on
your essentially at web applications and
then if you want to dump the data into
bigquery for additional processing you
then create a service project which
allows you to kind of create that
boundary of control for the services you
want to run and then create kind of a
secure perimeter using VP service
controls around that
so that you can restrict which services
can access that underlined data and then
ultimately bring those data back through
into GCP through either private access
cloud dns and cloud matting so you can
either replace your kind of subnets into
GCP or push our subnet pieces out so in
summary those are kind of the steps that
you take to pull things in and are the
building blocks of you building a secure
service on GCP and some of the pieces we
give you to fulfill your part of the
shared responsibility model so with that
I'm going to turn it over to Dan to talk
to you about Capital One's journey great
thank you okay Andy thank you for
opening the stage and allowing me to
present and open the windows on what's
actually going inside going on inside of
Capital One so I promised you a
cautionary tale
and this little creatures name is Altria
Altria is a rescue dog that my 12 year
old daughter picked up from the Richmond
Animal League in Richmond Virginia what
does this dog have anything to do with
the topic of shared responsibilities
compliance and controls on the cover
probably absolutely nothing but take a
closer look take a look at what's around
her neck so here's the tale it happened
shortly after Google 18 about a week
after Google 18 this little dog Altria
love her to death
she has no malicious intent whatsoever
but she's a runner she was trained as a
hunting dog she's an American hound so
on one particular night this was
probably after v escaped from the
homestead we live on a parcel out in the
country we kept talking about let's put
in a security fence an invisible fence
and we kept holding off because the
price was too high so I'm one particular
event
she left around 8 p.m. she has free run
in the neighborhood we live in this
river canyon on the James River we're
about a mile on either side there are no
fences and you can run from the
Chesapeake Bay all the way to the
mountains on this particular day it was
about 11 p.m. at night we were exhausted
we couldn't find her we came home and as
I was planning to go around the house to
check things out I felt this immense
pain in my leg and I jumped and wondered
what the heck happened so I looked down
and on the corner of the eye
there was a copperhead snake
unfortunately that take that snake took
advantage of the opportunity and as you
know later that day I was in the the
paramedics box I was at the hospital I
was being treated for a copperhead snake
bite so as you know in everyday life
there are risk scenarios everywhere this
is a very good example had we actually
put in the security fence we would
avoided Altria from escaping from our
private domain out into the public so as
a result we implemented this control
it's a shot-caller so as you approach
the fence she gets a really enlightening
experience if she's able to go beyond
that barrier into the public domain
there are some other controls that we've
implemented so what you might not know
about the risk rescue dogs is that when
you receive them you receive them with a
chip so if they are if they are captured
in public there's a way to identify
those we also added a a collar or a tag
the tag used to have only our home phone
number but she runs so much that we
actually had to put a cell phone number
because we would get phone calls at home
when we're actually out in the field
looking for her so as you see now it has
a lot to do with with cloud controls I'm
sorry with controls with shared
responsibilities it's the whole
community so let me take you into the
capital one journey I'm gonna open the
window for you for a moment you won't
see this often and I'm going to tell you
and share with you a few nuggets on how
we made our
journey into the cloud successful so
Capital One today has a significant need
for cloud because it enables us to
operate with the speed and agility
required to succeed in the digital age
our agile sprint teams work in two weeks
cycles and according to then
infrastructure must not be an impediment
as a result of them moving to the cloud
there are some stats and these are real
numbers we've moved from a development
environment build time of three months
down to 30 minutes new product features
which used to take a month now take two
days with unparalleled visibility into
our environments we have overall
improved security posture I'm going to
talk back on security in just a moment
our current cloud status is this we have
over 8,000 production applications and
services 6,000 additional services and
applications are in non production and
nearly 100% of our production and
development and test servers are in the
cloud additionally moving to the cloud
has increased our ability to secure and
manage massive volumes of data of high
quality data operating at a higher speed
with greater resiliency faster recovery
and at an extraordinarily lower costs
with cloud our technology organization
is free to do what we do best build
digital breakthrough experiences for a
customer if you are a customer of
Capital One feel comfortable and knowing
that we have your back and we are doing
our very best using state-of-the-art
technologies and best practices to
protect your sensitive data to make this
happen to make the security posture
happen we've implemented a methodology
around controls and compliance a lot of
organizations might call this cloud
governance or a governance function so
essentially that's what it is it's an
enterprise function at Capital One that
balances the need of of compliance of
cloud controls objectives and the needs
of various stakeholders from our board
of directors to executive management to
the enterprise Kim
like operations engineering and security
and cyber all of the communities that
come together to help enable our
security capabilities in the cloud and
most importantly then our divisional
customers these are our lines of
business our banking community were auto
finance community our card community
these are the application builders and
consumers of cloud services another way
to look at cloud control and compliance
is it's the set of totality set of
policies and procedures that help an
enterprise move towards its goals while
minimizing risk and conflicts so for us
our journey here our goal is all in on
the cloud and that's just about where we
are so let's go back to then what is
this cloud compliance function what I'm
going to share with you is a best
practice press practice example that is
aligned very closely with the cloud
security alliance methodology so think
of this as a box of cake mix where you
flip that box on the back side and it
gives you all the ingredients these are
all the ingredients to make it happen
these are the best practices you have to
include all of these in my opinion in
your program for cloud compliance to
have the maximum benefit to ensure that
you're doing the appropriate level of
due diligence for your environment I'll
go by these one by one and then I'll
give you some more detail on what they
actually mean so first off you must
document and maintain a catalog of
control objectives these objectives are
partially derived from NIST 800-53 or
Fed met rep moderate they're also a
compilation or a derivative of your
internal security policies and
procedures secondly for every single
service that our cloud providers offer
we perform a security control assessment
using a selected set of security control
objectives in that catalog and for now
our current state is about for our
catalog of about 300 controlled
objectives we use about
50 of those that are directly applicable
to cloud as it relates to our shared
responsibilities and of those 50 15 of
the control objectives are mandatory
requirements meaning that if they if the
service provider Google provides a
service to us and it doesn't meet any of
the 15
that's a showstopper so we'll just tell
Google we're not ready yet we need some
more features before it's safe for us to
consume that service next once you've
done the risk and the security
assessments you move into the phase of
performing the risk analysis on the gaps
that you've identified relative to your
control objectives so depending on which
industry that you're in you may have a
different set of objectives than what
Capital One has as a financial service
provider today we're using a composition
of qualitative and quantitative
methodologies we're looking very closely
at probabilistic risk analysis which
means that there's a probability in a
risk scenario of an event happening over
an annualized time period causing a loss
of money in a particular range so now
that you've identified your gaps now it
becomes a tough part this is a
continuous process on risk management
control implementation control
compliance control exception processing
you have to implement your controls you
have to monitor your controls for
compliance and you have to allow
application owners to make exceptions
against using the services that might
not have all the controls or for which
you're not able to meet all of those not
a requirement but the next one is the
divisional governance advisor and what
we've done is we've assigned a technical
subject matter expert like myself to
support a particular line of business
that translates everything that we've
talked about into terms that they
consume and most importantly as well
training that the associates to perform
that perform in this function need to
have background as a subject matter
expert in the cloud provided environment
back to shared responsibilities
component of this and he talked ad
nauseam about this this is really great
so I won't go into any detail here but I
wanted to share with you that we
understand this well and I'll just move
on to the next one which is a payout
slide this slide basically says for
capital one we look at shared
responsibilities from both a platform
perspective and an application
perspective let's take the application
perspective first I'm sorry the platform
perspective so my team working in cloud
governance we do everything that we
talked about before we assess the
services we ensure that they're they
they meet our security requirements we
work with cloud engineering teams and we
provision the services and make those
available to our consumers that leverage
those services by way of applications so
we're accountable for then assuring that
we implement platform Identity and
Access Management that we deploy the
operating systems appropriately meaning
that we provision system images rather
than using the cloud provider images we
provision our own so that we
appropriately harden them to meet our
internal standards we're accountable for
what we put into the cloud so we take
full responsibility for that one
particular example of a control related
to this is a notion of rehydration so as
a virtual machine ages it takes on
vulnerabilities because the
vulnerability aging process and so we
have a requirement to rehydrate every 60
days if you go beyond that bells and
whistles go off if you go past 90 bigger
whistles go off if you go to 120 the
cannons go off and so forth so I think
you get that so our cloud governance
functioned from a centralized
perspective is we make controls and
scripts available that either we can run
on behalf of the development community
or that we can give that give it to them
and they can actually run it for example
there might be a requirement to apply
labels or tags to all of your resources
if the development community forgets to
do that they can run a script to make
sure
they're compliant to that let's move on
then to the application if you build it
you own it that's the mantra at Capital
One so if we offer a service to you
you're golden you can use that it's been
wait-listed the controls are in place
but you have some accountability I'll
talk a bit more about that
accountability so wire cloud control is
important I wanted to make sure that you
had full visibility to that for Capital
One it's our mission and our fiduciary
responsibility if you take a standard
document classification or information
handling matrix you will find that your
proprietary or confidential data is
probably your most important asset and
requires a level of protection beyond
those that our company or public so what
we do and how we've bifurcated this is
we look at the controls in the in the
cloud control catalog in three three
particular areas as technical
operational and management and I'll show
you on the next slide how we codify
those but most importantly the controls
have to always be on the windows have to
always be locked so that means security
protocols public accessibility data
encryption identity access and PCI there
is no opportunity there is no tolerance
for control being off so where do cloud
controls originate I mentioned to you a
bit earlier that they might originate
from cybersecurity frameworks nest
FedRAMP and so forth here's a particular
small matrix of the the 14 control
categories in the NIST framework where I
bifurcated those by technical
operational and management so we take
our cloud control catalogs we look at a
service that Google has provided we
perform that security assessment the
diagram below or the colorful green red
blue chart is the actual detail of the
questions that we might ask and
incidentally I have to say that Google
has been an extraordinary partner in
this Google has our scripts they know
what we
choir they know when a service is ready
to meet the more the higher bar for
financial services industry and so they
are embracing that they're working very
diligently to say hey Capital One we've
got this new service and they know what
our requirements are so they know when
to actually make the ask and finally we
complete the service assessment we
deliver the package now it's important
to note here under item C that it's a
cross-functional team we include
governance we include engineering
resources cyber resources architecture
I am architecture and also our identity
I'm sorry our information assurance
third party management function where we
we fully validate we have an auto-fill
trail that our regulators and our
internal auditors can go back and say
did you ask that question google tells a
lot of good things about their services
but we firmly believe in trust but
verify so this is the final slide I've
got about 15 seconds or so and then
we'll save time for QA but here's the
payout and this is what what resonates
with shared responsibilities from an
application owner perspective here's
what it means if you have an application
let's take a basic multi tier
architecture application where you
you're going to need a load balancer a
web server application server or
database and file storage that
application or the type of application
may require that you adhere to an
enterprise architecture standard there
may be a defined architecture already
the architecture might even say in order
to meet the requirements for the
architecture there are certain cloud
services that you are mandated to follow
so the application owner defines the
application they choose the architecture
they select the cloud services that are
approved this is by no means the only
list of what's approved at Capital One
so we could put dot dot dot after you
select the approved services then you
become more aware of an application
owner of
what your actual requirements for
controls are so if you pick a compute
engine if you pick storage you will have
some requirements for identity access
data encryption and so forth so this is
really the whole story there's so much
detail here feel free to reach reach out
to me on LinkedIn if you have some
follow-up questions and we'll actually
go to back to Andy to close it out for
us thank you Dan so kind of in summary
throw one last slide so security of the
cloud is something the cloud provider
secures security in the cloud is
something that the cloud customer
secures for their data and their content
Google Cloud we look to empower you as a
customer with the visibility to control
and secure the things that you're
responsible for and as dan talked about
customers can be successful in cloud
using a very thoughtful process
structure and clean separations
responsibilities within their own or
[Music]